I am Claire your orbit driver  I am Carly your passenger are you famous  would you think that you live in a  mansion actually I have no idea who  lives there what do you mean  forty five minutes ago I rang the bell  when the woman that lives there open the  door I shot her in the face  you are sitting next to a sociopath so  here's the deal  if you tell me a really good story and I  will let you live what happened my  passenger from tonight she pulls a knife  on me attacked me if he finds me he will  kill me what is that  that's footage from inside of my house  here's looking at you Claire smile  you're on candid camera we gotta go I  know a place that we can lay low for a  while  how do you know every single thing that  I've done today  historians  I will break you  why are you doing this  you opened your door to a monster  you